- Vous êtes à Port-au-Prince.
Certains doutent fortement que
les meurtriers vont faire face
aux conséquences de leurs actes.
- Oui. Vous avez d'un côté
l'enquête policière avec
l'assistance des Américains et
des Colombiens et vous avez
l'enquête qui se passe au
parquet, c'est le commissaire du
gouvernement qui entend des
témoins et les a invités. Le
premier sur la liste, je vous
les nomme parce que c'est
intéressant.
Ce qu'ils ont en commun, c'est
que ce sont des opposants
farouches et très critiques du
président Moïse. On veut les
entendre parce que vous avez des
choses à dire.
Il y a les haïtiens qui
n'hésitent pas à les pointer du
doigt. Ils sont derrière ce
meurtre c'est certain.
Maintenant, on peut se demander
si évidemment on sera un jour la
vérité. On peut en douter parce
J'ai posé la question au doyen à
Port-au-Prince. On va entendre
la version de chroniqueur
judiciaire après. Qui n'est pas
la même.
- Parfois c'est un substitut qui
est monnayé, même le commissaire
du gouvernement. Personne ne
sait. Donc, ici, même la
personne qui a assassiné le
président, dès qu'il est
puissant,
- décret de l'agent, il est
sauvé. C'est l'occasion pour
nous de le prouver que la
justice haïtienne est capable
d'arrêter et de juger tout ceux
qui commettent des infractions.
Aller jusqu'au bout.
- Il y a des agents fédéraux
américains ont été dépêché en
Haïti.
- C'est une sorte de caution
pour le côté policier de
l'affaire. Il y a des Américains
et des Colombiens, ça donne un
peu plus de confiance pour les
haïtiens qui jusqu'à présent,
estiment que du côté de la
police. Les Américains sont
prêts à aider ils ont commencé
cette façon. On va entendre ce
qu'a dit le président des États-
Unis.
- Demain, d'autres personnes ont
été invitées par le commissaire
du gouvernement. Ce sont des
membres de la sécurité du
président Moïse, dont le chef
qui a effectué dernièrement
beaucoup de voyages en Colombie.
On se demande pourquoi et on se
demande pourquoi et comment ces
agents de sécurité ont laissé
entrer les mercenaires
Colombiens et laisser assassiner
le président qu'